we'll just go through some instructions
very quickly just reminded my name's
Lewis baseford I'm the detective
superintendent from the Metropolitan
Police I'm James Collis Chief
superintendent here in Sussex police Our
intention needs are just to read a short
brief updates from both in relation to
activity in the last 24 hours
um we don't intend to take any questions
at the end of this and obviously any
further information we'll release as the
time goes on
I can confirm that Constance Martin and
Mark Gordon remain in police custody
here in Sussex an application for the
extension of their detention for a
further 36 hours has been sought from
Brighton magistrates Court
the police Searchers of the baby
continue and we must consider that the
baby has to come to Serious harm
detectives from the Mets specialist
crime command are now leading inquiries
to locate the baby because of the
resources technology and expertise
available to them in this very complex
investigation
this is a hugely difficult and
painstaking search operation covering a
vast area of some 90 square miles
we're using every resource we have at
our disposal to find the baby
the police helicopters sniff dogs
thermal engine Imaging cameras and
drones continue to be used to assist the
met and Sussex police
and we've worked overnight
in conducting a number of those searches
specifically we have conducted searches
in New Haven and open areas to the east
and north of Brighton including the
South Downs
members of the public can expect to see
search teams working over the next few
days including the night
support from the public has been vital
during the course of the investigation
so far and we continue to appeal to them
for the information that they keep
providing
I would reiterate that members of the
public can help us by remaining Vigilant
and Reporting any suspicious Behavior or
items found in their Gardens
outbuildings and sheds between the 8th
of January and continence and Marx
arrest
equally if you are out walking in these
areas and you discover something you
think that we should know about please
don't hesitate to contact us no matter
how insignificant it may seem to you
before their arrests the last known
sighting of constance and Mark was in
New Haven on the 8th of January and I'm
therefore reiterating to the appeal to
members of the public between Brighton
and New Haven to report any potential
sightings or information
anyone with any sightings or information
that could assist the search is asked to
call the Met police instant room on 0208
3453865 or 999 with anything they
believe may be significant I'll now hand
you over to my colleague thank you so
hundreds of officers from Sussex police
and the Metropolitan Police have been
searching tirelessly overnight and that
search is continuing over an extensive
area today
I'd once again like to thank the local
community for their patience and
understanding while we carry out this
investigation and search
The increased police presence in is
likely to be in place for some time
still which will include additional
search parties extra patrols and how's
the house inquiries
we're very grateful for the many offers
of help we have received from the public
and for the huge number of reports we
have received with information
I would also like to thank the volunteer
search and rescue teams who continue to
support our search and remain such a
vital asset to the forces
please be assured that we have highly
trained and experienced officers
searching the area and we ask that
members of the public remain Vigilant
whilst out and about
please do report anything of note by
calling the Metropolitan Police incident
room on that 0208
345-3865 number or 999 in an emergency
thank you very much for your time and
patience today thank you very much